jacques duclos vous allez le voir
apparaître dans quelques instants sur le
petit écran
mais permettez-moi auparavant à moi qui
suis un de ses camarades de vous le
présenter brièvement ce qui me fera
d'abord dans la vie de jacques duclos
c'est la fidélité inébranlable à ce qui
fut l'idéal de sa jeunesse quand il
choisit de lutter pour le socialisme
challes jacques duclos
peut-être certains d'entre vous le
savent est né dans une famille modeste
dans les hautes pyrénées
dès l'âge de 12 ans et doit gagner son
pain il est apprenti d'abord à tarbes
ensuite il monte à paris comme on dit où
il se lie avec les socialistes comme
jaurès anatole france
il a 18 ans quand éclate la guerre il
est mobilisé il est à verdun il est
blessé et au lendemain de la guerre il
entend l'appel des traces de lénine aux
travailleurs du monde entier et il est
un des cofondateurs un des fondateurs du
parti communiste français
désormais on peut dire qu'il sera mêlé à
toutes les luttes ouvrières puisqu'il
est membre la direction du parti
communiste il est député bientôt en 1936
il est un des grands leaders du front
populaire et sous l'occupation et
aériennes ou sa tête est mise à prix
il joue un rôle de premier plan sur le
sol de la patrie dans l'organisation de
la résistance et de l'insurrection
nationale et cdapp cette époque je m'en
souviens que tu peux me permettre une un
souvenir personnel que le jeune étudiant
contestataire que j'ai été élu pour la
première fois le nom de jacques duclos
sur une feuille polycopiés qui était
jeune i qui était salie qui été froissé
et qui avait pour titre l'humanité je
dois dire que je m'en souviens encore en
tout cas depuis la libération jacques
duclos a poursuivi le combat pour les
grandes causes qui éclairait ses espoirs
d'adolescents qu'ils s'agissent de la
défense des revendications des
travailleurs français ou qu'il s'agisse
aussi de manifester sa solidarité avec
les travailleurs des pays colo diot télé
jacques duclos qui aurait pu comme tant
d'autres choisir de faire carrière
et qui a préféré être un militant il est
un homme politique mais il n'a jamais
été un politicien jamais son nom a été
mêlé au moindre scandale et même des
journalistes qui ne partage pas ses
idées ont tenu à rendre hommage à son
honnêteté à son intégrité
au cours d'un demi siècle qui était
fertile en événements de toutes sortes
et en tragédie aussi bien il n'a pas
cessé de mener le même combat
courageusement généreusement sans jamais
dévié de la voie qu'il s'est tracée et
je me souviens encore de la réflexion
peut être mélancolique que fit un jour
françois mauriac halle aux obsèques de
marcel cachin qui fut le compagnon de
lutte de jacques duclos qui fut le
directeur de l'humanité toute une vie au
service des classes ouvrières visé
françois mauriac toute une vie au
service des classes sourire cela mérite
le respect eh bien je crois que jacques
duclos pour les mêmes raisons mary le
même respect jacques du plomb je
n'appellerai pas monsieur le président
et je vais te tutoyer
je sais que je cours le risque de
choquer ou de surprendre tout au moins
un certain nombre de téléspectateurs
mais nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps
nous menons le même combat nous sommes
des camarades des amis et il ya entre
nous quelque chose de très fort et de
très précieux qui s'appelle la
fraternité alors pourquoi faire du
cinéma si choses ainsi m'exprimer
peut-être ce n'est pas conforme aux
usages mais c'est conforme à la réalité
puisque nous tutoyons dans la vie c'est
tout d'abord tu as bien raison de me
tutoyer puisqu'on hutteau rians ailleurs
et comme ça nous ne faisons pas du
cinéma l'île étaient appelés c'est la
vie tout ça vient alors à notre problème
c'est que je n'ai guère l'habitude à la
télévision de poser des questions je me
bats en général pour défendre mes idées
et la difficulté de te poser des
questions c'est que je connais en
général la réponse puisque nous
défendons l'un et l'autre la même
politique mais comme je reçois beaucoup
de lettres à l'humanité à l'heure
actuelle je voudrais me borner
aujourd'hui à être l'interprète
l'intermédiaire de ses lecteurs auprès
de toi pour que tu puisse répondre aux
questions qu'ils se posent alors jacques
duclos une première question qui revient
souvent
n'aurait-il pas été préférable qu'il y
ait une candidature unique de la gauche
vers nous avons pensé nous mêmes au
parti communiste français qu'il était
préférable qu'il y ait une candidature
unique de la gauche et à cet effet nous
avons fait des propositions au parti
socialiste nous avons demandé on élabore
ensemble un programme commun aux
formations démocratiques et une
socialisation professionnelle
après quoi on aurait pu procéder à la
désignation concertée d'un candidat
unique de la gauche
malheureusement la réponse du parti
socialiste a été négative
le congrès socialiste d'alfortville a
désigné gaston defferre et à partir de
ce moment-là toute possibilité de
désignation d'un candidat unique était
avait disparu c'est dans ces conditions
que le comité central de notre parti a
été amené à me désigner comme candidat à
la présidence de la république et les le
soir même de ma désignation
j'ai donné à ma candidature la
signification d'une candidature d'union
des forces ouvrières et démocratique
par conséquent voilà la réponse que je
puis faites à cette question elle est
simple et claire est l effet
parfaitement clair mais voilà nous
sommes dans la situation suivante c'est
qu'en définitive il n'y a pas eu
semble-t-il enfin certain nombre de
candidats à gauche un certain nombre de
candidats endroit en définitive le choix
essentiels devant lequel se trouve posée
les électeurs c'est le choix entre la
poursuite sous une autre forme de la
politique était menée hier et une
nouvelle politique que tu es le seul à
les firmes à défendre oui il y à deux
politiques qui s'affrontent mais elle
cette politique et les représenter en ce
qui concerne la politique nouvelle c'est
moi qui la représente
et il ya des candidatures de divisions
dont l'importance
est ce qu'elle est mais en passe de nous
il y à la politique réactionnaire qui a
deux défenseurs deux candidats monsieur
pompidou et monsieur poher monsieur
pompidou c'est le candidat de la
continuité puisque il est le candidat de
l'udps et r il est le candidat en
quelque sorte officiel le candidat du
gouvernement
eh bien il est le représentant d'une
politique que nous avons été amenés à
juger depuis déjà longtemps au fond le
bilan de 11 ans de politique est assez
l'eau et sinon pour ne reprendre que
quelques points je peux constater ceci
c'est que l'hostilité opposés au
gouvernement aux revendications de la
classe ouvrière et de l'ensemble des
masses laborieuses ainsi que la carence
du gouvernement en matière d'éducation
nationale furent à l'origine des
événements de mai et de juin
ça c'est indiscutable au surpluss on
peut constater que le gouvernement avait
par exemple sur le plan de l'information
fait de la rtf son instrument de
propagande
alors ce que nous considérons comme nous
l'avons déjà dit comme l'avons dit dans
un projet de statue de nous avons
élaboré à cet effet que le rtf
n'appartient pas au gouvernement
c'est un service public qui appartient à
la nation
et puisque je j'ai l'occasion de
m'adresser aux françaises et aux
français sur le petit écran
je veux dire que nous communistes nous
demandons la réintégration des
journalistes qui ont été licenciés
l'année dernière pour l'avoir demandée
l'objectivité de l'information alors rtl
et puisque je parle d' objectivité je
suis bien obligé de reconnaître qu'on
qu'aujourd'hui alors rtf en dehors
évidemment de cette émission électorale
et dans d'autres moyens d'impression
d'expression plus exactement
eh bien on voit très nettement que ma
candidature est d abord désavantagé par
rapport à certaines aux autres ce qui
veut dire que même certains qui parlent
d' objectivité ont un sens très relatif
de l'objectivité elle même donc ce
gouvernement la politique
gouvernementale
à ce bilan négatif
que nous sommes amenés à juger de plus
il faut bien dire que dans la dernière
période
il y a eu là la spéculation la
spéculation qui a fait qui a fait de
bonne affaire puisqu'il ya eu 15
milliards de francs qui se sont qui sont
partis à l'étranger et on voudrait bien
connaître l'identité de ceux qui ont
joué le deutsch mark que contre le franc
parce que vous qui m'écoutent et vos
françaises et français qui m'écoutent et
vous n'avez pas vous exportez des
milliards en suisse pour rejouer le
dessus sur le deuil chebab pas non plus
je n'ai pas exporter mais il y en a qui
ont exporté et les noms de ceux là vous
ne connaîtrez jamais ils sont cachés
parce que on ne veut pas frapper les
spéculateurs ça aussi c'est un des
traits de la politique menée par le
gouvernement de cette politique qu'il
faut combattre et à ça nous voulons
opposer nous une politique de démocratie
avancée cette démocratie avancée doit
l'être dans tous les domaines économique
social politique et elle doit préparer
dans notre esprit
la marche au socialisme pour notre pays
une marche pacifique qui sera fondée sur
la prolonger populaire car nous ne
pensons pas que ce sont quelques
minorités qui peuvent imposer leurs
volontés
c'est le peuple lui même qui doit
prolonger son destin et nous avons
confiance dans la force créatrice du
peuple et dans sa volonté de changement
voila voila par conséquent la politique
de changement que nous opposons à la
politique que des pans monsieur pompidou
en tant que candidat officiel et oui
justement se défend aussi la question
que je voulais poser que des aimants
réalisme et monsieur per et monsieur
power défend exactement la même
politique c'est si vrai c'est qu'il ne
veut pas dissaux de l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'il veut collaborer
avec les députés gaullistes qu'ils ont
pas majorité dans cette assemblée
nationale voilà qui est significatif
ça veut dire que ce qui veut dire que
les hommes qui sont les véritables
maîtres du pays
les hommes qui sont dissimulées derrière
le gouvernement
regarde le parlement qui tire les
ficelles ce que l'on appelait hier les
les 200 familles ce que ce que les
hommes des monopoles capitalistes les
détenteurs de la véritable puissance
capitaliste cela ils doivent examiner le
jeu électoral avec beaucoup de
tranquillité sommes solides six pompes
il gagne nos gagnants et si pau et
regagne lot gagnant aussi par conséquent
pour nous il n'y a pas de différence
entre ces deux candidatures qui s'en
tape appelé qui ont pour objet de
présenter deux variantes d'une même
politique et il est regrettable
justement que des la gauche dans la
gauche non communiste il ya des éléments
qui est favorisé ce jeu au lieu de créer
les conditions d'une candidature unique
de la gauche
en tout cas pour ma part j'ai conscience
face aux candidatures de puissances
d'argent que je combats d'être le
candidat du peuple et j'ai conscience
aussi que l'avenir de la france et dans
le peuple c'est le peuple qui est
porteur d'avenir et c'est pourquoi je
demande aux françaises et aux français
de voter pour admire
[Musique]